there's a family in our driveway Jordan
Peele broke a box office record for his
newest horror film us now the film
centers around an all-american family
trying to escape their vengeful
doppelgangers and in true peel fashion
the film is definitely more than meets
the eye here are some of the top Easter
eggs you might have missed and warning
major spoilers ahead
the most obvious theme is probably the
one of duality bloodthirsty clones
attack the Wilsons and other Americans
throughout the film
even before the devil's attack were
introduced to the tiler twins the house
of mirrors it's a portal between two
worlds scissors the weapon of choice for
the tethered are two blades connected by
one screw and the tethered are described
as shadows of their more privileged
counterparts but there's one major
easter egg that sticks out and it goes a
lot deeper than you think
1111 2 spiritually significant numbers
that mirror each other 11:11 was seen
numerous times throughout the movie we
saw it first on the homeless man sign at
the fair in Adelaide's flashback which
reads jeremiah 11:11 alluding to the
biblical scripture later on the tethered
version of the man has one-one-one-one
gouged in his forehead young Adelaide's
thriller shirt that her dad wins for her
is prize number 11:11 as the Wilsons
settle into their vacation home the
number eleven pops up everywhere
like when Gabe's watching the Giants
game the score is tied 1111 and when
Adelaide is tucking Jason in at night
the clock hits 1111 let's take a closer
look at what this number means the
jeremiah 11:11 verse is about God
bringing Wrath to a group of people that
won't be able to escape but the number
11 itself might be even more interesting
aside from the biblical meaning 11:11
has other spiritual significance in
numerology the number 11 represents the
twin flame Twin Flames not to be
confused with soulmates is the belief
that everyone has a spiritual
doppelganger twin flames may appear
different on the outside and have
different personalities based on
upbringing
but at their core they're the same 11
also represents a spiritual gateway or
portal into the spirit world it's
meaningful that in US 11s are shown
right before we see the tethers come
through their world into ours this can
also be seen in many pop-culture
references for example the a tea set
Netflix series stranger things
emphasizes Elevens role in connecting
and severing to alternate the parallel
worlds and Pele uses 80s pop culture
continuously throughout us people born
between the years 1960 and 1980 are
known as Generation X now popular
nicknames to this group include the lost
or forgotten generation mainly in part
because they're perceived as being stuck
in the shadows of the generations that
came before and after them so it only
seems fitting that most of the
pop-culture references in us are from
the 80s the names of the VHS tapes seen
at the beginning of the film are huge
Easter eggs the man with two brains is
an old Steven Martin comedy and
obviously plays on the theme of duality
chud is a movie about monsters that come
out of a sewer similar to where the
tethered come from the right stuff is a
movie about a government program that
included animal experimentation and
resulted in human death red tells
Adelaide that the tethers were created
as a result of a government experiment
gone wrong and The Goonies is a comedy
about a group of kids who go on an
underground treasure hunt and face
dangerous obstacles in addition to the
VHS tapes The Goonies is referenced in
Easter eggs throughout the movie in us
Fred says it's our time up here this
mirrors the Goonies line down here it's
our time it's our time down here and the
fast food spot in us copper pots seems
like the perfect play on the Goonies
character Chester copperpot
a scavenger hunter that went missing and
eventually died while trying to find the
underground treasure this could
reference the to Adelaide's ultimate
fate another iconic film that Pele
confirmed as an influencer is The Lost
Boys a horror comedy about two
California brothers who fight a gang of
vampires if you're Martian in fact all
of the santa cruz beach scenes in us
were filmed at the exact same amusement
park featured in The Lost Boys the
parents in the beginning of us actually
referenced that something is being
filmed at the carousel and there's a
scene in The Lost Boys filmed at the
carousel vulture also points out some
Nightmare on Elm Street Easter eggs like
Pluto's melted face which looks
strikingly similar to Freddy Krueger's
the iconic Brown glove and the battle
scenes in the boiler room
finally nothing says duality like the
references to the shining Greg uses the
baseball bat for defense just like
Shelley Duvall's character Wendy and
after being injured Craig's limp looks a
lot like Jack's and of course the creepy
Tyler twins
[Music]
finally the boardgame guess who is a
tongue-in-cheek reference to the twist
ending
the pop-culture references and overall
plot bring home one of the biggest
themes of the movie the dangers of
classism and inequality the tethered are
literally described as shadows of the
people above forced to live out the
actions and the will of the privileged
in the film the only thing stopping the
tethered from moving up was a downward
moving escalator escalators are often
symbols of how moving up is easy when
privileged this shows how the inverse
can trap you synonyms for tethered
include restraint leash and chain which
is why many have noticed the parallels
to the prison industrial complex this is
seen in their jumpsuits and their lack
of ability to choose for themselves like
the tethered many of America's
incarcerated don't have the opportunity
to vote and rely on the actions of those
privileged enough to do so it's
important to note that the tethered say
that they're human beings genetically
only they've been handed unfortunate
circumstances the act of mimicking is
also an important aspect the tethered
pretend to do everything from riding
rides to playing games to raising
families following those above without
any actual payoff mimicking plays into
our obsession with consumerism without
the means to keep up with the Joneses
peel doubles down on this team with his
characters Greg for example represents
middle-class privilege from his
collegiate shirt his obsession with
consumerism and his out of touch with
reality dialog Adelaide's true identity
signifies that the tethered aren't
traditional monsters but just like our
protagonist without the same opportunity
it's the ultimate depiction of nature
versus nurture which is what makes this
film so unsettling using metaphors and
pop-culture references Pele shines light
on how terrifying inequality can really
be and how in the right circumstances
anyone can become their own worst
nightmare any Easter eggs we might have
missed let us know in the comments below
you
[Music]